bon ce journal mais tout de suite on va
seront regardés dessous nous sommes en
direct de pessac et vous voyez le
ministre de l'économie qui vient
d'appuyer sur un bouton pour la première
fois et cet historien vous allez voir
une pierre euros là monsieur le ministre
vous attendiez à 3,2 à écouter voilà le
premier euro france essor c'est le
premier en europe
le voilà alors heureux oui à une comme
vous le savez il ya une phase française
et une phase européenne et ça reprend
notre slogan qui est que nous serons
plus forts en europe parce que ce pays
européens mais que nous restons français
alors cette machine va fabriquer des
euros jusqu'en 2002 elles sont
fabriquées très vite vous en avez déjà
plein dans la main elle fait à peu près
la taille d'une pièce de 10 francs oui
c'est à peu près la taille d'une pièce
de 10 francs c'est pas exactement la
même le dessin maintenant on est connu
je crois que tout le monde se plaira
ensuite à l utiliser il y en a il ya eu
8 milliards de pièces qui doivent être
produits d'ici le 1er janvier 2002 quand
ça sera mis en circulation
entre-temps seront stockés et puis le
jour venu pour les janvier 2002 tout ça
tout ça sera distribué justement les
français qui nous regardent et qui nous
écoutent ne pourront pas les toucher
avant 2000 avant 2002 l'âge est un
privilège à vous aussi d'ailleurs vous
la touchez mais ensuite tout ça sera
fait évidemment et stockés de façon
secrète et puis accumulé pour que les
pièces soient prêtes
ça c'est les pieds d'un euro vous savez
qui est aussi des centimes qui a des
pièces de deux euros vous sera prêt pour
la date prévue juste un mot ce sera pas
facile de les cacher parce que ça va
représenter 30 mille tonnes fabriquées
en trois ans ce qui représente environ 4
fois la tour eiffel jean-paul merci à
monsieur strauss kahn et puis jean paul
si vous pouvez me vendra mieux un petit
complément souvenir encore rien ne sort
d'ici à ok c'est noté avec merci on a
vécu donc ce moment historique où leur
mère
2 nous aurons tous dans nos poches donc
cesser euros il a été heureux de vous
faire vivre en direct donc de pessac
merci jean paul chapelle on va
maintenant